hey let me give you an update about
what's going on with politican politican
is a political convention that is taking
place not this weekend but next weekend
in Los Angeles it involves a lot of very
toxic and unproductive debate but a lot
of big progressive names have been
invited and so when I was invited I said
I should do it even if the debates are
not individually that delightful I think
just being included in this group is a
really really good thing initially I was
gonna do one debate plus two panels
everything exploded where it wasn't
clear that I was doing anything I was
put on a panel about the future of
Democrats and I said okay I mean I can
do that but I'm not a Democrat I don't
know if I'm the right person and I think
that that panel maybe is no longer
happening I'm on another panel called
should we be socialists which is an
interesting one about whether Democrats
should run more as socialists now I'm
not a Democrat or a socialist but it's
an interesting topic and that's gonna be
moderated by Sam cedar as of right now
I'm on the panel with Kyle kolinsky of
secular talk Bakari sellers it's been
going back and forth between whether the
fourth panelist is Markos Meletis from
DailyKos of anak or ana kasparian from
The Young Turks I don't know the problem
is I don't think there's any socialists
on that panel and I'm not a Democrat so
it seems if the conversation is should
Democrats be socialists you should have
at least some of each I don't think
there's a single socialist on the panel
but we're going to talk about it might
as well just change the topic at that
point right yeah rather than getting a
whole new list of guests just change it
to something else should we be Social
Democrats maybe maybe that's a better
way to go yeah then I was put on a panel
about fake news which was supposedly
going to be moderated by Sally cone the
panelists were going to be me and three
others I was told it's confirmed all of
my events were on Saturday so I went
ahead and booked my flights and then it
popped up that it seemed like I'm just
debating someone named the roving
millennial the roaming roaming roving or
roaming the roaming Milan roaming
millennial who I googled then it appears
to be a mid-20s white nationalist woman
I was never asked do I want to debate
her I never agreed to that I don't know
how it turned up
and now it looks like maybe they're
moving back off of that and it's gonna
be a panel format about about fake news
you know the thing the problem I have is
if I'm going to debate a white
nationalist I can't debate them about
fake news and pretend like it's just
normal to be a white nationalist the
topic would have to be you're a white
nationalist right I mean that's the
topic doesn't make sense and the match
up doesn't make sense they're all for to
on that front but yesterday big breaking
news I was proposed to have a panel
slash debate where it would be
Kyle kolinsky of secular talk teaming up
with me against Candace Owens
Candace Owens and we don't know if it's
Candace and Charley Kirk they're both
part of this thing called Turning Point
USA I think it's some right-wing
activism thing or Candace Owens and
former CIA agent Dan bond Geno who just
makes a I think he just now criticizes
Democrats in the left I don't know
exactly what he does either way I think
that's gonna be pretty interesting Kyle
was told that it's Candace Owens and
Charley Kirk I was told that it's
Candace Owens and Dan bungee know so
maybe they haven't worked it out but
that is actually an interesting debate I
went ahead and changed my flight's
that's going to be on Sunday so now I'm
coming back the following Monday it
could all get canceled but as of right
now that's what I'm doing and if you
could indulge me what's the topic for
that panel oh yeah they have it called
something like how are we going to get
along which I don't think anyone's gonna
stick to I think it's going to be a
debate of left versus right wing
ideology yeah talk policy and none of
this free speech stuff I think too we
got to talk about health care we don't
got to talk about taxes yeah like let's
get into the meat of this stuff that's
what I want to do and Kyle and I will be
hopefully meeting in LA Friday Saturday
to strategize about this they they could
back out the people on the right lots of
people lots of right-wingers have backed
out I'm not cleared to talk about some
of the right-wingers that have backed
out but many of my friends thought that
they were doing certain things at
politican and they aren't so it's next
week it should really get figured out
definitively be it should be figured out
definitively pretty soon anyone who
wants to go can go
tickets are available online Google
politican tickets it's in Los Angeles I
know that there are people already who
have written in saying they are gonna
make the trek out to Los Angeles this is
this is listen this is why we have the
show this is why we have membership we
have a need to be out there we ask for
support on patreon this stuff is
important we're able to do all of this
different stuff because of the
infrastructure that that we built and
this is the latest and a Kile kolinsky
David Pakman versus Charlie Kurt Candace
Owens debate I think could do really
really well for exposing the sort of
emptiness of some of the ideologies that
people on the right have been purveying
relatively successfully yeah I hope it
pans out I really do especially because
we're only nine days away from you know
but seeing how so many other of these
panels and these debates have just been
getting cancelled you have never booked
in the first place yeah who knows what
will happen yeah they uh I don't want to
say more but if let me just put it this
way I hope someday we all come clean I
think people are maybe waiting for after
politican with the right-wingers who
effectively chickened out of certain
debates I think people in the audience
would be stunned to hear who some of
those individuals who claim to be all
about debating and then letting the best
ideas rise to the top like cream on top
of milk yeah we're going to hopefully
someday tell those stories and by the
way quick note before we go to a break
we are keeping audience questions the
when I floated getting rid of audience
questions deluge of 99% people saying do
not get rid of audience questions but I
like the curated nature of audience
questions on Friday distinct segments
from live calls so we're keeping them
and we have some good ones this week and
people have been submitting them and I
encourage you to keep submitting those
it's a great time to be a viewer of the
David Pakman show a little calm stuff
coming up oh yeah and with audience
questions here to stay new studio coming
up and all sorts of exciting things so
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show if you want to see behind the
scenes pictures of last week's
conference in Las Vegas and next week's
politican I will be backstage posting
pictures Pat
from the green rooms if I'm allowed in
and they don't cancel everything I'm a
part of at David Pakman on Instagram
follow the show follow me
quick break